when i was 23 years old i did stand up  and this beautiful white girl goes  you know i want to [ __ ] you right and i  did right i had i had to work at the  panic in the next day which is a coffee  shop in la jolla and i remember in the  morning i was there and i just couldn't  wait to tell somebody and i remember  some guy going like god that pastries  hasn't come i go i know the one that's a  piece i got laid last night  and i didn't have to pay for it yeah it  was unbelievable yeah right and they're  like oh relax dude you know what i mean  calm down but i just remember like it  being well people do that  now with work  like if we go to the store oh i hate it  if we go and you'll go like so how's  your how's your hand or whatever like  you'll just be making small talk yeah  it's it's uh my hand's okay it hasn't  affected shooting at all  you're like  uh what do you mean what do you mean oh  i didn't tell you  oh yeah yeah